il est au cœur de l'action
depuis mardi Sébastien immobilisé sur le
terrain si nuit d'une violence rare
c'est aujourd'hui un policier épuisé et
dans l'incompréhension
les premières nuits étaient vraiment
vraiment intenses
je pourrais même parler de scènes de
guerre à Dijon c'est pas habituel c'est
pas habituel ce genre de heure la peur
tout le monde l'a qu'on soit policier
qu'on soit pompier qu'on soit gendarme
qu'on soit comme vous citoyen lambda les
forces de l'ordre font face à des tirs
de mortier et de cocktails Molotov
[Applaudissements]
des commissariats sont attaqués 700
policiers gendarmes blessés à travers la
France sous le marche blanche pour un
décès de ça c'est entendable c'est
concevable mais à partir on passe une
après une deuxième phase s'attaquer à
des forces de l'ordre qui font que leur
travail au quotidien
c'est pas entendable je suis pas là pour
pour essuyer des jeux de projectiles mes
collègues également on est là pour pour
servir pour servir les concitoyens
sur le terrain les policiers font face à
des groupes très mobiles et très jeunes
souvent des adolescents avec un
sentiment de défiance vis-à-vis des
forces de l'ordre excusez-moi de
l'expression c'est des Minos j'ai un
certain âge j'ai plus de 20 ans 25 ans
que que ces jeunes là donc c'est
c'est ouais c'est compliqué on est tous
une grande partie père mère de famille
voilà ça peut être là voilà ça peut être
l'enfant d'un fonctionnaire vous voyez
ce que je veux dire ils savent même pas
aussi certains pourquoi ils sont là on
leur pose la question pourquoi vous êtes
là bah moi je suis parce que voilà il y
a un tel qui m'a dit de venir là il y en
a ils sont complètement déconnectés de
ce qui se passe vraiment
poser la question aux jeunes il y en a
ils savent même pas pourquoi ils sont
ils sont là des violents urbaines qui
fragilisent un métier déjà sous tension
l'an dernier 11000 agents ont quitté la
police 15000 la gendarmerie du jamais vu
mais pour Sébastien hors de question de
démissionner j'adore mon métier j'adore
ce que je fais je suis vraiment bien
j'adore ce que je fais mais
effectivement voilà on
veut du soutien on
des moyens parce que le métier de
policier c'est un beau métier c'est un
très beau métier de métier de policier
voilà on veut juste que nous
on veut du respect on va y arriver dans
l'apaisement on a senti une accalmie en
espérant que que ça dure et petit à
petit on je l'espère fortement que tu
rentreras dans l'ordre après ces
épisodes de violence urbaines deux
personnes ont été condamnées en
Côte-d'Or d'un côté six mois avec sursis
probatoire de l'autre quatre mois de
prison